depois vem a palavra transplante
ninguém imagina assim a complexidade que
tem em volta do transplante a um
transplante com doador falecido uma
pessoa morreu de maneira precoce teve
morte encefálica e virou doador a
família em drama dados desse sentimento
da morte prematura da perda inesperada e
tem que decidir se deve ser doadora de
órgãos não vai autorizar ou não a doação
e tem a locação do órgão tem que ter uma
regulamentação teria então você aloca o
ângulo no primeiro paciente da fila pra
que ele porque até você consiga dessa
forma tem a credibilidade da sociedade
por outro lado no transplante com doador
vivo você tem uma pessoa que vai doar um
órgão que vai sobre submeteu a uma
cirurgia vai ficar com o órgão - sem
precisar baseada principalmente na
relação afetiva que ele tem com a outra
pessoa
é curioso que acontece assim quando o
pai ou a mãe do
essa relação afetiva mais intensa que
existe nenhum pai ou mãe fala que vai
não vai dar para o filho e por outro
lado quando um filho quer ou precisa do
apoio pai olha que nós conversamos com o
pai ocupava com a mãe falando
ele é muito jovem hoje a expectativa de
vida é muito muito muito longa
pode ser que ele precisa de dois riscos
vivem 85 anos que a expectativa de vida
de quem tem 20 anos hoje 85 86 mais de
90 anos ao pai falou acho que não vou
aceitar atuação o filho chora o filho
chora falar eu quero doar de qualquer
jeito o filho não está pensando com 85
anos agora tem 20 tem 30 anos e é nisso
que ele está pensando mas o pai fala
assim eu tô em diálise
eu estou bem na diária eu sei que o
transplante é melhor mas essa diferença
ela não é suficiente para justificar eu
deixar o meu filho único
então o transplante como eu disse tem a
complexidade no seu entorno é muito
grande precisa do controle social
o brasil tem um controle social a cin
exuberante tem um sistema nacional de
transplante em brasília cada estado
brasileiro tem uma coordenação estadual
afirma
o transplante está nessa coordenação
ditador nesta coordenação da escola
estadual
o brasil é o maior programa de
transporte público do mundo
ele é o segundo estado foi mais
transparente do que o brasil mas dentro
do sistema público quem faz mais
transplante é o estado é é o brasil
essa é um quadro do século 14
a mostra é um evento que é uma
representa uma lenda do século 3 2
santos são cosme e damião na época eles
eram médicos eram médicos árabes que
foram educados na grécia que estava
fazendo esse transplante aqui em roma em
roma é um um gladiador e pop falecido em
combate a perna dele foi retirado e
colocado não sou cristão idoso naquela
época não tinha nenhuma estrutura nada
só foi uma imposição de tecido e diz a
lenda que ele saiu caminhando
imediatamente e até principal e pronto a
provocação deles foi falar o equipamento
é antiga
isso é só uma lenda mas isso contribui e
se esse quadro ele está distribuído em
todas as igrejas do mundo todo
ele contribui imensamente porque a
resistência das religiões a doação de
órgãos ou transplante seja mínima mina
até testemunha de jeová que não aceita a
doação de sangue não há certezas no
sangue não tem nenhuma nenhuma nenhuma
restrição ao transplante tanto com
doador vivo como doador falecido e
também a doação de órgãos no nosso mundo
contemporâneo e se o professor joseph
moore que fez o primeiro transplante de
rim em 1954 em boston e um gêmeo
univitelino foi o primeiro transplante
do sucesso fez em 1954 e ele estabeleceu
a técnica cirúrgica que é utilizado até
hoje eu tive a oportunidade única de
conhecer há poucos anos atrás dois ou
três anos atrás
ele tinha 94 anos e estava como
professor de todos na harvard eu tive a
oportunidade de conhecer por dois dias
têm contato com ele por dois dias e
chama a atenção e 94 anos nem a energia
que emana dessa fase
a asmo que sai dessa facilidade um
vencedor e é a conversa dele não é uma
conversa de lamúrias
no meu tempo era assim agora nesse tempo
ninguém quer nada com nada não falou
isso
ele conversava comigo sobre o nosso
tempo
por isso que aqui estamos aqui quem está
sentado junto com ele só eu deixei só me
ouvir e escutar pelo que o que o que ele
falava
antes dele o seu pt a medalha também
ganhou o prêmio nobel de medicina e foi
quem descobriu ele nascido no brasil
nasceu no brasil o pai dele estava o
engenheiro mecânico que estava
trabalhando no rio de janeiro ele nasceu
no brasil e depois voltou para a
inglaterra depois de 44 anos de idade e
ele descobriu que o transplante quem faz
a rejeição do transplante é o sistema
deficitário e ele abriu a possibilidade
de você intervir nesse sistema então
primeira intervenção que teve
intervenção bem óbvia é óbvia se quem
destrói o transplante é o sistema
linfóide vamos fazer uma radiação total
do sistema linfóide e vão evitar a
eleição deu certinho e victor rejeição
mas ninguém em uma pessoa dessas pessoas
reconheciam mais uma infecção bacteriana
não tinha rejeição mas morreu de
infecção
então só dava certo transplante com o
gêmeo univitelino em 1960 para cá foi
descoberta já que opina que também
bloqueia quase todos os reforços mas
bloqueio de maneira mais seletiva
os impostos que são direcionados por
enquanto a gente é para tentar fazer a
rejeição e depois de 1980 prá cá
o transporte deve ser feito só entre
gêmeo univitelino passou a ser feito com
tito do tipo de doador vivo e também
contra os planos do ator falecido no
brasil o primeiro foi feito em 1965 pelo
professor no sábado dia em que os outros
órgãos coração pulmão fígado ainda
ficaram assim como a obra de pioneiros
de 1980 prá cá quando descobriu-se que
os kulina que está destacada é uma droga
mais específica que segura mais a
rejeição influencia - na na resposta
contra a infecção e é mais efetiva então
jogos coração pulmão fígado que se não
funcionar na hora
o indivíduo morre naquele ano 21
funcionar na hora fica um pouquinho de
ali ele funcionar começar a ser feito e
hoje fazem parte da rotina dos meus
planos
todos esses órgãos são transplantados de
rotina da mesma forma o ruim é
transportado hoje e se vocês observarem
e se nenê se neste gráfico de 2000 pra
cá não teve nenhuma droga nova que
apareceu que foi fez parte do arsenal
terapêutico exame face beta 7 seu nome
mas assim o complexo do que os outros os
outros nomes que está escrito aí que
parece todos eles são mais ou menos
complexos mas ela sempre o mais complexo
até mesmo na forma de administração dele
não sou de ministro e esse remédio uma
vez por mês
não precisa tomar o remédio aderência
dos pacientes e seria ótimo
nem tenho uma série de incógnitas ainda
nós já usamos aqui no brasil e
tratamento clean e ensaio clínico mas
ainda não temos uma definição se esse
remédio vai ser mesmo incorporado
definitivamente na nossa no nacional
terapêutica
independente disso 15 anos sem nenhum
remédio um resultado de todos os
transplantes vem melhorando
gradativamente
como tudo que você faz com repetição
sistemática do mesmo processo vai
repetindo o time vai melhorando aqui
nesse blog nesse box amarelo
nós estamos vendo os transplantes num
projecto num programa de transplante de
larga escala que foi feito em 1908 2003
em box amarelo mostra a curva de
sobrevida se chama isso aqui chama curva
de sobrevida atuarial agora a chance de
um transplante dá certo depois de um ano
com doador falecido dador vivo resultado
é melhor é menor do que 80% nesta
primeira curva a curva o que está
embaixo aqui a cuba que tem a última
curva que é a curva dos últimos quatro
anos mostra um resultado que é a chance
de dar certo do transplante com doador
falecido é superior a 90%
então sem linha nova descoberta sob a
repetição sistemática do mesmo
procedimento
o resultado do transplante melhorou
bastante nesses anos então todo mundo
pergunta qual todo mundo pergunta agora
ea fila toda hora você escuta perguntar
quando é que vai acabar
é fácil responder que nessa primeira
coluna a fila de transplante de córnea é
outra coisa não pode ser doado até seis
horas depois coração parou não tem
limite de idade não tem que tomar
remédio não tem rejeição então
praticamente não existe tanto a filha de
korda nenhum lugar do mundo afirma o
brasil em alguns estados existe aqui no
estado de são paulo em três meses você
tem espantado
nós fazemos atender uma necessidade do
transplante de córnea que a 90
transplantes de córnea por milhão de
habitantes por ano
o transplante de rim precisava fazer 50
60 nós conseguimos fazer metade desses
transplantes e essa fila vai ela vai
aumentando no brasil tem 120 mil pessoas
em problema crônico de diálise mais ou
menos metade delas poderiam ser
transplantadas nós conseguimos fazer só
metade desses transportes a um
transplante de fígado coração pulmão a
filha pequena
somando todos eles têm menos duas mil
pessoas na fila
isso porque se o paciente não foi
transplantado no período de um ano
hoje até espantado ele faleceu então a
filha pequena no transplante de rim se
não fossem as pancadas e fique problema
como o crónico de diálise
eu tenho um paciente é mais de 30 anos
em diárias que não conseguiu ser
transplantado por razões diversas
é ruim mas é uma forma de gente que tá
30 anos em diálise e trabalha entre
bonito e trabalha trabalha trabalha
normalmente
agora o que é a questão principal que
nós vivenciamos assim em relação ao
transplante há atualmente
assim nós observamos esse mapa esse
máximo esse mapa ele mostra uma
disparidade geográfica muito grande
tanto do programa de transplantes onde
você vê a cor verde escura é que tem um
trânsito muito grande
mais de 70 transplantes por milhão de
habitantes por ano
a cor branca não tem nenhum e o brasil
tá aqui nessa cor nessa corrente
remediar esse é essa é uma situação
absurda que vivenciar essa disparidade
econômica e cultural que tem no mundo
ainda não
na nossa fase de desenvolvimento mas o
transplante ele acompanha essa é se essa
essa disparidade
a gente ficou se olha o mapa do brasil
aqui você vê que o brasil ele é assim
tem uma coisa mais ou menos
intermediária no centro 30 transplantes
por milhão de habitantes por ano
mas se nós olharmos o brasil região por
região há uma disparidade geográfica que
tem no mundo que acompanha também a
disparidade socioeconômica da região ela
fica bem claro no brasil também na
região sul ea região sudeste ela tem a
cor dos países mais desenvolvidos
estados unidos europa e bonzinho na
região norte e na região nordeste
principalmente na região norte muito
menos agora é essa
essa essa disparidade
ela pode ser corrigido em alguns estados
como por exemplo ceará em pernambuco que
o empenho das pessoas no programa de
transplante e harmonia entre os
transplantadores de um sistema público
faz com que o desempenho do número de
transplantes no ceará em pernambuco seja
até melhor do que no estado de são paulo
mas está diluído aqui naquela região
e aqui nós vamos estão vendo aqui aqui
em causa é a etiópia líbia é um país que
nós temos 11 um programa de atuação na
etiópia
cheguei lá hoje de manhã nesta semana
nós fizemos quatro transplantes estão
desenvolvendo um programa de
transplantes pet shop um país que tem
uma série de complicações sucede é bem
pobre
alguém pergunta se tem sentido fazer
transporte de obra tem sentido fazer
transplante obra tem sentido fazer um
pouquinho porque o transplante ele a
complexidade do transplante ele
pavimenta o caminho para que as outras
situações com menos complexidade passou
a ser feita com o melhor para melhor
qualidade também
então ele trabalha com bastante
dificuldade mas ele seguramente vão
conseguir fazer chegar um dia a um
modelo de transporte que nós temos aqui
no brasil nós não vamos conseguir
resolver a fila de transplante
logo que a fila de transplante vai ser
sempre maior do que a expectativa de
vida das pessoas está aumentando então
não me pessoas que entra na fila está
aumentando
noite violenta diminuindo graças a deus
está diminuindo então tem muito menos
doador
nós temos quatro possibilidades o cheiro
transplante seria fazer um transplante
com órgão de um ano de animal
esse é mais difícil de dar certo não
conseguiu ainda controlar a rejeição
agora que controlar a rejeição tem um
monte de vírus que vivem acomodado em
harmonia na sala do povo quando foi
transferido o homem não sabe o que vai
acontecer
e também não sabemos se a sua órgão do
corpo quando ele foi espancado no homem
se ele vai viver a expectativa de vida
que tenho um pouco de pouquinho 18 anos
e vai viver a expectativa de vida do
homem
a droga foi então vamos fazer isso com
células tronco todo mundo falar a área
toda vez aparece na televisão isso
fizeram obra partir de células tronco se
fizer um ano a partir de células tronco
não sei por que não foi feito ainda uma
cela do sangue é muito mais fácil com
171 do sangue alguém quiser doar ou
então j de plantas têm muito mais fácil
fazer a hipótese é a célula derrota de
planta produza uma coisa só
só insulina precisa de um sensor até
hoje células tronco não resolveu isso
então eu não espero e nem
xenotransplante nem célula tronco vai
fazer parte da missa da minha vida
biológica
outra possibilidade é você fazer de
engenharia você pega um órgão doente ou
ruim doente tira todas as células as
células doentes de mantém a estrutura em
depois ela é proporcionada com células
normais do seu próprio organismo e vai
adquirir o formato do rio também é
difícil acreditar que isso vai dar certo
assim já dá certo diz é um transplante
transplante de osso ou se a gente tira
um fragmento do osso um fragmento do
osso é o osso longo deixa menos 70 graus
todas as semanas morreram umas 70 graus
mas fica aquela matriz aquele esqueleto
que é basicamente formado por um calço e
é só você coloca as células da própria
pessoa vão lá ocupam aquele lugar não
ser rejeitada ela pode não pegar mas ela
não vai ser não vai ser não vai ser não
vai ser rejeitada eo artificial
aquele que nós temos de maneira mais
efetivo é a implantação do ventrículo
esquerdo
o presidente já tem pessoas vivendo com
o órgão
foi implantado há mais de cinco anos no
coração implanta um coração artificial
implantado há mais cinco anos mas ainda
não é uma situação assim também como
parte do cotidiano em uma coisa que nós
podemos fazer para ajudar que dependendo
da situação coletiva
a correção da disparidade geográfica
também não depende de nenhuma nenhuma
descoberta nova no espelho deste ano o
transplante não depende de nenhuma
descoberta nova depende de uma
iniciativa coletiva vontade coletiva
essa é uma campanha da associação
brasileira de transplantes se você quer
ser doador de órgãos a vida de sua
família e sua família vai entender se
que entender isso como seu último desejo
é até uma forma de você continuar após a
morte
contribuindo com a sociedade é um jeito
simples a ver sua família sua família
vai entender isso como o seu último
desejo e vai entender isso como uma
forma de você continuar contribuindo com
a sociedade
eu quando comecei a falar eu comecei
dizendo que o transplante é muito mais
complexo do que do que a cirurgia ou do
que a rejeição ou diz que a descoberta
de uma nova droga
eu falei que envolve uma série de
sentimentos envolve o sentimento que nós
conhecemos bastante e vou deixar esses
últimos 20 segundos
algumas imagens que mostra bem todos
vocês vão entender bem quando eu falei
que o transplante envolve nosso redor e
envolve uma série de outras coisas mais
complexas como os sentimentos diversos e
vocês vão ver nessas últimas imagens
[Música]
o luso na escola está próximo é é é é é
é assim
[Música]
a globo
[Aplausos]